i felt so embarrassed that he could kick
me to the ground
in front of people
and be more embarrassing i didn't know
what to do about it he's howling
like
like an animal
well holding the dog out of the window
everyone just froze day after day of
revolting revelations in court isn't
making either johnny depp or amber heard
any more popular they're sending a lot
of attention they craved for their toxic
relationship tommy i
i just don't know what to make of this
gate and i seem to spend half my life
listening to these two in courtrooms
slagging each other off and making vile
accusations about each other i don't
know who to believe i don't know how
much of it is true they're two actors
what do you think well you nailed it
we've got two actors so we're going to
get a performance of a lifetime probably
from both of them but i got to tell you
this it makes sense to me that amber
heard is of aquaman fame because
everything is seeming a little fishy
here but i'll tell you pierce what
really bothers me most about all of this
is that we learned this week that the
aclu they were actually the ones that
drafted the op-ed for the washington
post in the first place and they wanted
to time the release of the op-ed to the
aquaman press tour so all of this seems
fishy all of this seems very
performative here i'm sure that they had
a very toxic relationship but in the
court of public opinion i would say
amber heard is not making out too well
to me this trial is is so this case is
so not entertainment for me
and what i what i worry about is it's
gonna damage
you know future men or women coming
forward and making their own claims or
the justice system having doubt or not
believing because at the end of the day
you know we can't get away from the fact
that two women get killed every week in
this country by their former partner or
their current partner as opposed to 12
men a year so i have to kind of remind
myself that i'm glad that people are
aware of the situation which is an
epidemic of domestic violence and
coercive control and any form of abuse
but i also think
that to look at this case as
entertainment is damaging theatrics of
johnny depp and amber took another
dramatic turn today as dep's former
lover kate moss the supermodel gave
evidence from her home in
gloucestershire she made a very brief
appearance specifically to testify that
she was never pushed down the stairs by
debt contrary to rumors resurfaced by
amber heard in the case two weeks ago
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him did mr depp push you in any
way down the stairs
no
during the course of your relationship
did he ever push you down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
or threw me down any stairs and as far
as ever heard saying that um she had
been
tossed down flights of stairs or or
beaten up by johnny depp or anything
like that i don't believe it in for one
new york city second i mean look look
what happened between the two of them
she severed his fingertip off right i'm
sorry
i mean i i gotta say janice i've watched
the whole the whole thing from time to
time uh the clips and so on we're just
increasing kind of revulsion really it's
like the worst dirty linen ever washed
isn't it
don't you feel dirty watching this trial
i mean i have been watching it like this
but i'm planted to it at night i do find
that the jury's verdict is unanimous
ladies and gentlemen this concludes your
service in this case i want to thank you
again for your dedication and your hard
work during this trial and i know i
speak for everybody here
when i appreciate tell you that we
appreciate your sacrifices and your time
and your public service in this matter
okay well complete slam dunk victory for
johnny depp in that defamation case
against his ex-wife amber heard a
disaster for amber heard because johnny
depp has not only won on every count of
this case improved the defamation was
done against him by his ex-wife but he's
been awarded a total of 15 million
dollars including 5 million in punitive
damages so this is a wipeout for amber
heard it's a complete uh vindication for
johnny depp right let me just read you
there's a statement here from amber uh
her which i'm going to read in full and
get your reaction to it the
disappointment i feel today she says is
beyond words i'm heartbroken that the
mountain of evidence still wasn't enough
to stand up to disproportionate power
influence and sway my ex-husband i'm
even more disappointed with what this
verdict means for other women it's a
setback it sets back the clock to a time
when a woman who spoke up and spoke up
could be publicly shamed and humiliated
it sets back the idea that violence
against women is to be taken seriously i
believe johnny's attorney succeeded in
getting the jury to overlook the key
issue of freedom of speech and ignore
evidence that was so conclusive that we
won in the uk i'm sad i lost this case
but i'm sadder still but i seem to have
lost a right i thought as an american to
speak freely and openly now tommy larry
i would say no one's damaged her free
speech she was allowed to speak freely
and openly but the jury concluded that
what she was saying was a lie and not
just a lie but a deliberate malicious
lie designed to destroy her husband and
that's why they found against her and
that's why they've awarded him so much
money she should be ashamed of herself
and we'll see if she can make a comeback
but i don't think so you can't go after
people you can't cancel them for no
reason this is a big victory for johnny
depp and the war against cancel culture
i mean on the other thing apparently
i was going to say the other thing about
this is that you know for amber heard
she's an actress but i don't think she's
going to get any work after this is she
because the the jury actually concluded
but she acted with malice in other words
she has deliberately lied here about him
to damage him
listen she's lied she was in the court
in england and she lied under oath in
england when she said that she'd given
her seven million to charity and she
hadn't and elon musk had made a donation
under her name of the pittance of what
it should have been
so she lied under oath so that wasn't
looking good for her and and the thing
is no i don't think that any big film
studio will touch her right now well
johnny depp won 10 million dollars in
his defamation trial with ex-wife amber
heard he spent a large chunk of it
celebrating with a curry in birmingham
reportedly racking up an incredible bill
of fifty thousand pounds i'm joined now
by the owner of varanasi restaurant
muhammad hussain
well good evening to you you must be you
don't look that cheerful but if johnny
depp had dropped 50 grand in my
restaurant i'd be thrilled
hi good evening ps morgan uh yeah we're
very excited to have johnny depp in our
restaurant um but there are a lot of
rumors going around at the moment in
respect to how much he actually spent in
the restaurant
um and his unconfirmed amount because we
haven't actually disclosed anything as
of yet
all i could say is i was in a situation
one time where i got blamed for
something that i didn't do
it cost me movie jobs for several years
and it caused me a bad reputation and
finally
the truth came out but the truth came
out after
i lost movies and i lost jobs and
and so i felt bad for somebody that
uh
is trying to get chopped down by some
gold digger you know
you think that's what she was
absolutely absolutely in the closing
arguments the depth lawyers called your
testimony the performance of a lifetime
what do you say to that says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers when i asked
his lawyers why do you think you won and
the answer i got was
because she never took responsibility
for anything i have a lot of sympathy
for amber heard i agree with the
couple's marriage counselor that they
were both abusive to each other and
there's no question that she was
vilified on social media as she says she
had to go into court past blocks and
blocks of johnny depp super fans holding
up signs that she deserved to die i mean
this was a horrific experience for her
she stands by her testimony my concern
for her is is she going to get hit with
a new defamation case because now she's
out there calling him a liar